so I'm really quite excited today
because we've had the paper published
about our research to understand the
paper you need to appreciate that I'm a
very bad chemist in making molecules my
skills in the lab in preparing things
have always been pool so I've always
been fascinated by machines in which you
pump in the chemicals are going to react
and outcomes product these days my group
uses a reactor which is just a piece of
metal tube which if you look through it
is empty and we fill it with a catalyst
which turns reactants into products so
the actual reactor looks like this with
tubes to pump things in and want to pump
them out we pump our reactants in with
high pressure carbon dioxide so called
supercritical fluid removes the need to
have other solvents you can see there's
some kit bang tiny here which I use for
demonstrating supercritical fluids to
visitors to my office now the problem
with reactors like this is that there
all sorts of different reaction
conditions that you have to alter to get
the best result you have to change the
temperature so you get the best
temperature you have to alter the flow
rates of the chemicals through it and in
the case of carbon dioxide you can vary
the pressure and this is quite a slow
process it takes a long time and to be
honest it's really boring or can be
changing the temperature just a tiny bit
looking at the results changing it again
and so on now we've made it easier some
time ago by putting a machine on the
outflow of the reactor which analyzes
the products automatically a gas
chromatograph which will tell you how
much of the different products you've
got so this brings me to our new paper
you can see it's here
it was published online today so you can
see it'll read it still says these are
not the final page numbers so it's
really hot it's called self optimizing
continuous reactions in supercritical
carbon dioxide the point about this
experiment
the thing that's really important is the
first word of the title self optimizing
so what we've done is to use the signals
from the gas chromatograph to adjust the
conditions of the reaction so you begin
by telling the reactor which product you
want you give it a few starting
conditions so it knows approximately the
right temperatures and pressures and
then you let it get on with it it
analyzes the first four different sets
of conditions and then the computer
attached the Machine calculates what it
thinks is a better condition and it goes
on gradually improving things till it
gets the highest possible yield of the
product and you don't need to do
anything you can be lying in bed and if
the machine is working away and the
thing that's exciting is that it takes
away all the boring bits and lets you
think about the science but let's go to
the lab and have a look and so you can
see it for yourself this is when my
other students Ryan who's now using the
machine to go on to do other reactions
beyond what we've already published
because it takes quite a long time
between writing the paper and getting it
published in this reaction and the one
we used to prove the idea we're reacting
an alcohol not ethanol but Penton all
that has five carbon atoms with a
molecule called dimethyl carbonate which
makes an ether the mixture of the two
starting materials Penta low and DMC are
in this bottle here and they're bit
going through this pipe and into a pump
and the pump pumps the reaction solution
into the reactor
and at the same time we have a second
pump that pumps in the carbon dioxide
the cylinder that holds the dioxide
is in the cupboard behind me the
reactance and the carbon dioxide a mixed
here one comes in this side one that
side and this measures the temperature
here there is so-called pre heater which
warms things up and then it goes through
the reactor which is exactly like the
one in my office but it has a wood metal
block around it to heat it up then the
product comes out of this pipe up to
here this is a valve which takes small
samples into this machine that analyzes
it the gas chromatograph and the rest of
the flow which we haven't analyzed
continues on into this valve that
releases the pressure and the product
goes into the bottle here the important
thing is really the signals that go to
the computer then over there to where
the results are annulled now we
calculated in the paper that in the old
way we used to do it where we change the
temperature and look at that effect and
then raise the pressure a bit change the
temperature and so on the experiment
that we published would have taken
eighty four days to do it and the
computer control
it only took 36 hours so it's a huge
saving in time so some people might
question is this really chemistry I
think it definitely is it's on the
borders of chemistry and chemical
engineering but if you're interested
like I am in greener ways of making
chemicals you can't just make tiny
amounts in the lab you have to be able
to do it on the larger scale eventually
to build whole factories to do this so
I'm very excited because I believe this
is the way of doing chemistry far more
cleanly than many of the chemical
reactions are done now so here you can
see how the computer is changing the
conditions and homing in round here in
the best possible yield for that
particular product so like all bits of
ence done now it's not the professor who
does the experiments that there's a
whole team and everybody makes their
contribution which is why there are so
many authors on the paper and apart from
that there are acknowledgments on the
paper to those that have helped us
particularly in this case the
technicians who made some of the
reactors and the other things that we
use so we're really proud the whole team